there are individuals once I described
as Mecca who are say when they say this
landmass this was they really wants to
say I am a peaceful individual and I
have no problems with other religions I
do not want to be engaged any politics
of any sort or to link politics with
religion please
right right right and now I would say
would be the majority of Muslims
worldwide I'm not sure you agree with
that but it seems to me that it isn't
self-evidently the case that the
majority of human beings are violent and
warlike and so ice my sense is is that
given the essential peace peacefulness
of most people they're going to take a
look at the Islamic doctrine and extract
from it those elements that are
supportive of that more individual peace
but that still leaves open the question
of exactly what the doctrine means as a
set of motivational principles and that
seems to be a big part of the current
problem and also the need for current
discourse what I would hope is that it
would be possible to undertake a
dialogue with Islam let's say between
Islam and the West or between Islam and
judeo-christianity and to find within
Islam itself the seeds that would enable
that dialogue to occur so that some sort
of long term negotiated conceptual and
practical peace could be attained but
the more I've read about Islam the more
difficult it is for me to understand how
that might be managed especially because
of its well because of the warlike
tradition that emerged from from Medina
and then at a staggering rate from that
and also the thing that's quite quite
disconcerting to me I mean it's not like
Christianity hasn't been rife with
internal divisions like that between the
Cubs and the Catholics but I mean it it
also was the case that what you might
describe as the civil war that's been
occurring within Islam more or less
started as far as I can tell more or
less started the day that Muhammad died
and has never stopped since then and
that also seems to be well obviously
it's a problem for the Islamic community
itself but it also seems to be a problem
an increasing problem for the West is we
can't not be tangled up in that yeah we
have to share the planet with one fifth
of humanity and it's very clear that
things have to change and that is beauty
of Muslims
the theological underpinnings of the
religion and as far as I'm concerned
this is being pushed by those that I
call reformers or modifiers yeah and
these are individuals maybe now a little
bigger there are groups we are forming
groups and maybe even being led by
summation States leaders of countries
for that change the big question is are
they going to agree on what to change so
what is inbuilt into Islam is this idea
that men cannot argue with God you
cannot unsubmitted and edit to the Quran
and it's the same thing you know
Mohammed was is seen by Muslims as
infallible yeah never made a mistake
so it's an uphill battle for those
Muslims inside Islam who were seeking
modernization or seeking the power to
agree on you know how to edit score how
to fish to eight Muslims to accept a
truly peaceful right and a truly
tolerant idea of religion that separates
religion and politics respects the
rights of women respects the rights of
people of other faiths and people within
Islam who want to leave their face so I
don't get the theological underpinnings
for that yeah that's the click button
within the his Lama well yeah and the
danger there too is that I mean when
that sort of thing is attempted often
reform from within a religious community
one of the dangers there is that instead
of reforming it peacefully all you do is
add another sect to the court yeah for
us secular people it seems from from a
distance it seems kind of easy to say
well why don't they just separate
religion from politics and you want to
be a pledget
they can be religious but to look at it
that way is simplistic because then you
people who want to be religious this
Medina subset who want to say for a
medina Muslims an expression of his
Muslim Ness is to convert you to Islam
yeah to kill me as an apostate its to
get
to cover up it's to keep warning lies
about life life today and all that it's
the thing that's that made me I would
say nervous to some degree from the
perspective of someone who analyzes
totalitarian ideology because the thing
about totalitarian ideology is it tends
to be totalitarian right it's all
absolutely all-consuming and yeah that's
that's why also when I've been assessing
because I've done a fair bit of research
into comparative religion and and and
done my best to expand my knowledge base
and I've always had a hard time with
Islam in that regard because it's
difficult for me to extract out the
purely religious elements and to compare
them to let's say religious sentiments
that have emerged across across
humankind in all sorts of different
times and eras and to separate that from
the political doctrine and sometimes I'm
tempted to think more that Islam you
know broadly and vaguely speaking is
something much more like a political
movement than it is in fact like a
religious movement it is a political
theory and it's a political movement
it started out even in Mecca in the
early days come to my god which was a
political message it wasn't that just a
religious lesson right even in the early
days in Mecca was absolutist Islam by
its nature is absolutist because it
seeks complete and total submission of
the individual to God and in Medina
Muhammad then claimed Iran with a
political movement for how society ought
to live the relationship between the
individual and God the relationship
between men and women the husband and
wife the relationship between parent and
child the relationship between the
government the Collegium and the
subjects and their duties it has a court
system it has a military system so from
it's very beginnings Islam was more of a
political theory there it was an agent
as we understand the agent today